E
, I AM THERE TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF ANY AMERICANS.
>> JOINING US NOW IS LAUREN
BEAUFORD.
TO CONGRESSWOMAN, I WANT TO GET
TO YOUR VIEWS ON THIS MAP FREAK
ON TWITTER, BUT I FIRST WANT TO
ASK ABOUT THE EXCHANGE FOR
SECRETARY BECERRA.
HE BELIEVES THAT THIS TYPE OF
SURGERY FOR NON- ADULTS IS
PROTECTING CHILDREN?
REALLY?
>> LAURA, THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
DISGUSTING AND AS YOU STATED ON
YOUR SHOW, THIS IS NOT ONLY
REPULSIVE, BUT ITS IT'S
CHILD-ABUSE.
THE SECRETARY, HE IS A LAWYER,
POLITICIAN HE'S A BUREAUCRAT AN
EVEN HE IS MAKING THESE
PROFESSIONS LOOK BAD.
IT IS A SAD DAY IN AMERICA WHEN
THE SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES IS USING HIS
POSITION OF INFLUENCE TO PROMOT
GRUESOME GENDER REASSIGNMENT
REASSIGNMENT SURGERIES ON
CHILDREN.
NOW, WE KNOW THAT HIS RECORD IS
NOT VERY GOOD.
IT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY PATHETIC.
PROTECTING CHILDREN AND PARENTA
RIGHTS, SO WHEN HE CAME INTO OU
COMMITTEE, I ASKED HIM ABOUT
THOSE THINGS.
I ASKED HIM IF OUR TAX DOLLARS
WE'RE GOING TO THESE SURGICAL
GENDER REASSIGNMENT ON CHILDREN
THESE GRUESOMELY GENDER
REASSIGNMENT AND HE HAD NO
ANSWER.
I ASKED HIM IF PARENTS WHO DON'
AGREE WITH HIS CARE AND DON'T
WANT TO MUTILATE THESE CHILDREN
IF THEY ARE AT RISK OR AT DANGE
OF HAVING THEIR CHILDREN MEANT
REMOVED FROM THEIR HOME STRAIGH
HE DIDN'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
THAT EITHER.
I ALSO ASKED HIM IF MEN CAN GET
PREGNANT AND HE DANCED AROUND
THAT QUESTION, SO I HAVE MANY
QUESTIONS FOR HIM THAT I ASKED
HIM ON THAT DAY AND WE ARE
SEEING THAT THEY ARE DOING
ANYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO
PROTECT THESE PEOPLE WHO WANT T
SEXUALIZE AND GROOM OUR CHILDRE
AND NOW HERE ON YOUR SHOW
TONIGHT WE HAVE THESE MINOR
ATTRACTIVE PERSONS, WHAT IS THI
WORLD COMING TO.
FIVE YEARS AGO IF YOU WOULD HAV
SAID THIS IS WHERE ALL THIS IS
LEADING, WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
CALLED CRAZY.
HERE WE ARGUMENT YOU HAVE
SOMEBODY SAYING THAT IS TOO
DEGRADING TO CALL IT SO WE'RE
GOING TO CALL IT MAP, WHAT IN
THE WORLD IS HAPPENING IN
AMERICA?
>> IT MAKES IT SOUND BETTER.
>> GET IT RIGHT.
REALLY, IT'S NOT SOMETHING
COMFORTABLE TO TALK ABOUT.
IT'S NOT COMFORTABLE
CONVERSATION TO HAVE BECAUSE WE
SHOULDN'T BE TALKING ABOUT THES
THINGS.
LAURA, THIS ISN'T PLEASANT, BUT
WE NEED TO KNOW IF OUR TAX
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO REMOVE
YOUNG GIRLS, WE NEED TO KNOW IF
THEY'RE GOING TO REMOVE THE
GENITALIA OF YOUNG BOYS, THESE
ARE CHILDREN.
AND MY MESSAGE TO THE BIDEN
REGIME IS GET OUT OF OUR LIVES,
GET OUT OF OUR HOMES.
THESE ARE OUR CHILDREN.
>> THEY CALL THIS CONSPIRACY.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IN
RESPONSE, THEY ARE SAYING YOU
AND OTHERS, PROBABLY MYSELF, WE
ARE SPOUTING CONSPIRACY THEORY
BECAUSE WE ARE ACTUALLY QUOTING
THESE PEOPLE WHETHER IT'S ON
TWITTER OR WHETHER WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE INABILITY TO
DEFINE A MOTHER AND THEY ARE
CALLED BIRTHING PERSONS NOW SO
IT DOESN'T OFFEND THE RADICAL
FRINGE.
THOSE ARE FACTS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO ACTUALLY
SPEAK IN TERMS OF FACTS.
THEY WANT TO THROW OUT
MAJORITIES LIKE OH, IT'S A
CONSPIRACY LIKE THE HUNTER BIDE
LAPTOP WAS CONSPIRACY.
WE WILL GET TO THAT NEXT SEGMENT
.
>> THAT'S EXEC THE RIGHT, EVERY
TIME THEY DON'T LIKE THE FACTS
COMING OUT THEY CALL IT A
CONSPIRACY.
WE HAVE BEEN PUTTING OUT
INFORMATION ALL ALONG WHERE WE
WERE CALLED NAMES AND CONSPIRAC
THEORIST, JUST FOR NOT GOING
ALONG WITH THEIR AGENDA.
THEY EVEN USE THE TERM ON THEIR
OWN WHENEVER THEY AREN'T FALLIN
IN LINE WITH THEIR AGENDA.
I TOTALLY BELIEVE THAT THE
SECRETARY NEEDS TO BE REMOVED
FROM HIS POSITION.
I WOULD LIKE TO CALL ON HIM TO
BE REMOVED FOR WHAT HE IS DOING
TO PROMOTE THIS MUTILATION OF
CHILDREN IN AMERICA.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING
WHAT'S COMING OUT OF HIS
DEPARTMENT.
NOT ONLY THAT, BUT LOOK AT
WHAT'S GOING ON ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND REMOVING TITLE 40 TO
RIGHT BEFORE THE SUMMER MONTHS
WHEN THEY KNOW THERE IS GOING T
BE AS SURGE.
>> IT'S ALL PART OF THE PLAN.
IT TRULY IS.
>> WE HAVE TO GO, CONGRESSWOMAN.
EVERYTHING IS BEING TURNED
UPSIDE DOWN.
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND, THIS
ISN'T SOME KIND OF WEIRD LIGHT
COINCIDENCE, THIS IS ALL
HAPPENING FOR A REASON